the 2012 draft produced a bevy of
superstars beginning with Andrew Luck
round three pick number 75 5 spots after
a putter
Russell Wilson Luke Kuechly a top 10
pick that year RG three number two
overall things didn't work out although
at first it looked like they were going
to because Wilson and Luck ended up
number four number three on the Chris
Sims top 40 quarterback countdown luck
was for Wilson was three we are
redrafting at least the top six picks
from the 2012 draft based on the teams
that had those picks not who would you
draft in those spots the teams that had
those picks as those teams were
constructed at the time this is gonna be
fun this is gonna be fun after we get
through the rig coin toss go ahead oh
you want me to call go ahead let's see
give me tails
oh man Kristin what's wrong
geez hey here's the thing here's the
thing I I almost didn't want to win this
one I'm thinking about deferring to you
ah because I think you would put Andrew
Luck on the Colts still with the number
one overall pick and it's hard for me
not to put Andrew Luck there but we had
an entire lost season for Andrew Luck
Russell Wilson we haven't had a lost
season Russell Wilson has been a model
of durability and we've seen what
Russell Wilson has done without a whole
heck of a lot of help now he did have
the legion of boom early in his career I
I tell you what all things considered
I'm going Russell Wilson he's he's he's
been healthy I I'm going Russell Wilson
yeah I hear you Mike I'm not mad at you
there I think I would have gotten
Russell Wilson with my number one pick
too it's really close I mean what do you
want to go luck Wilson either way you're
gonna be in good hands but yes I think
with the special skill set Wilson has
shown and you know the fact that yeah
the help thing I think probably does
just give them the slight advantage over
Andrew Luck but gosh I know both are
phenomenal I'm taking Andrew Luck with
my pick let's just get that on the road
right now okay I mean we know we know
Russell Wilson's the man
definitely I'd be funny to see him
playing in a Colts uniform but Andrew
Luck is going to be my second pick or my
pick to start my first round because
yeah I mean Andrew Luck is a franchise
everything you want as far as a
quarterback is concerned and yes we lost
that we've been missing a full seat yeah
other than that one year there's nothing
really you can look at in his game and
go oh gosh that's a glaring negative oh
he has this just issue
I mean his only issue was he wanted to
win too much to where you know he put
his body in harm to too often and of
course it came back to bite him in the
butt eventually but Andrew Luck has been
phenomenal to this point and I think now
he finally has a team around him to
where you know there it's just gonna
accentuate what he is as a player like
that word extenuate I haven't pulled
that one out in a while I like
accentuate I'm not sure you've ever
pulled it out before and if you've used
it before you probably didn't pronounce
it correctly so kudos to you thank you
here's where it gets very interesting
right look the Cleveland Browns back in
2012 they got that third overall pick
because they had traded up with the
Vikings so they could draft Trent
Richardson later in the round they
drafted quarterback Brandon Weeden that
didn't work out and my guess would be
that for the Browns that year there
would be a desire to get yourself a
quarterback that could potentially be a
difference maker with a proper level of
coaching oh my gosh I'm so torn here I
think they would have taken a
quarterback and I think they should have
taken a quarterback in I think the guy
had taken this spot I hate to say it I I
don't think I can say it
I think it's Kirk Cousins that's a good
I love it that's you you taking them
that is amazing that you're taking oh
yes look I consider what the Browns have
needed where they've been how bad
they've been Cousins comes in and
cousins you know he has look yes he
hasn't been much more than a 500 level
quarterback but my god wouldn't
improvement that would've been for the
Browns over the past seven years yeah
right they still didn't make it to 500
last year there was seven eight and one
he's better than the Brown
we're in last year and we're praising
the Browns well yeah definitely needed a
quarterback I mean I hear that and Kirk
Cousins has shown that he is a franchise
quarterback certainly better than
Brandon Weeden everything like that so I
just love that you Victor Cousins is so
great you're oh you're good old crack
you know crack cancer challenge buddy
there you're picking but I mean I mean
again he's exceeded expectations I do
think there's other guys here you commit
a case for as far as what would a fit in
Cleveland because you know we have some
players here that we know are so good at
this point that you could justify almost
the thought of saying best player on the
table or something along those lines
okay so I wouldn't have been mad at you
there either way
okay so man now I got to get down to the
Minnesota Vikings here who at that time
took Matt Khalil right to be the
franchise tackle and do all that it
didn't exactly work out quite quite all
well I okay gosh what do I want to do
here I guess if I look at the 2012
Vikings and I just want to make sure one
thing Mike Zimmer was there in 2012
right am I not there no it was Leslie
French it was Leslie Frazier that fits
even better
okay so Leslie Frazier there he's gonna
go defense here in this case scenario
okay where we were looking at this
football team Leslie Frazier the
defensive system he comes from I got a
hard time saying they can pass up a
Fletcher Cox here I'm taking Fletcher
Cox all right yes I mean they had some
good good defensive linemen at the time
but Fletcher Cox has proven to be one of
the best defensive players in football
over the last three or four years and
anybody not named Darren Donald okay
this is the best defensive tackle in
football I mean he's just a monster man
he's got great intensity he can just
beat people with power and for a guy
that's 315 320 pounds man is he some
athlete too so I'm gonna go with
Fletcher Cox he's one of my favorite
players in the NFL doesn't get enough
recognition that I could certainly see
the Vikings going that direction yeah
you know what I think that would be a
good selection even though at the time
the Vikings had real need that
quarterback position now they had taken
they had taken Christian Ponder the year
before it would have been hard to
justify taking a quarter
again that's why I went with Kirk
Cousins with the third pick because the
Browns took a quarterback that year
later in round one and didn't work out
and that's why I'm tempted to give Nick
Foles to the Jaguars here with with pick
number six simply because they have him
now and we've seen what Nick Foles can
do but I think Nick Foles has to have a
certain level of coaching needs to be in
a certain system I don't know that would
have worked in Jacksonville back in 2012
and also they had Blaine Gabbert that
they had drafted a year before so I
don't think they'd do something like
that so I guess I go I guess I go Luke
Kuechly right I mean he won a few spots
lower to the Carolina Panthers he's a
guy who becomes the leader of your
defense the heart and soul of your
defense a guy who makes the rest of the
team around him better and yeah I you
know you can't go wrong now they had
Paul Poe's lovely at the time but he had
been around for a while you find a way
to make it work with both of them Paul
Post loves me you trade him because
Kuechly ended up being that good and
right now it kind of gets overlooked now
that we've lost some of the leaders in
Carolina Thomas Davis has gone Julius
Peppers has gone Keith Lee is still
there and and I think still in many ways
he's he's the guy who's the center of
that defense and he would have been the
center of that defense in Jacksonville
going on nine years now ya know I'm with
you there and you know what we don't
talk about Luke Kuechly enough as one of
the best defensive players in the sport
he just kind of go unnoticed under the
radar you know he's not flashy all the
time but my gosh it's a Hall of Fame
career I mean there's no other way to
say it to this point I mean Kiki has
been absolutely phenomenal you know
athleticism reaction skills physicality
found a way to change the way he kind of
plays right to keep his head out of
danger because we had the concussion
concerned concerns and then he's truly
like a quarterback on the defensive side
of the ball getting everybody organized
and and getting everybody in the right
the right position so that's a good pick
by you there okay this is where the
Dallas Cowboys I'm not sure what to do
here I don't know if there's really an
offensive guy that I look at and go okay
that's that's where we go here that's
worth that to me is coming down to
really I look at two positions for the
Cowboys at that point
it's either you know do I want to go
with the pass rusher and a Chandler
Jones or do I want to go with like a
Bobby Wagner okay at the middle
linebacker position because I think they
have Shawn Lee at the time already and
their deed their defensive linebackers
were not horrible
no I'm wrong I'm going I'm going Bobby
Wagner here I'm going Bobby magner at
middle linebacker and I'm gonna pair him
with Shawn Lee Bobby Wagner just like we
talked about with Luke Kuechly he's on
he's on his way to Canton Ohio it's a
Hall of Fame middle linebacker he's you
could argue was the best player on one
of the best defenses we ever saw in the
history of the NFL with the Legion of
boom I look at that Cowboys roster at
the time they got DeMarcus Ware they got
Anthony Spencer I don't think they're
gonna waste a pick on on a on a Chandler
Jones and then the quarterback play was
pretty good at that time too with
Brandon Carr and Morris Claiborne to
where I don't want to go Stefan Gilmore
so I think the best player available and
what somewhat of a need here would be
that middle linebacker position and you
pair him together with Bobby Wagner who
is just does it all I mean physical as
can be again like Kuechly I mean just
unbelievable athletes smart quarterback
of the defense always in the right
position and does more than what he's
asked at times to yeah I think that's
not a bad pick I mean Bobby Wagner
quietly putting together those Hall of
Fame credentials you want to go one more
round we have time to go one more round
are you ready I'm ready Bay Buccaneers
at number seven all right the Buccaneers
are on the clock it's a it's a
fast-moving clock whose number 8 stats
let me just make sure I got it remember
as Miami number that's Miami I you know
I'm down you mentioned Chandler Jones
and I've been Josh Norman all due
respect is a little overrated I'll go
Chandler Jones okay you're gonna go
Chandler Jones there yeah okay I mean
III got a I'm pulling it I did not
expect to go here to the Miami I'm just
pulling it up real quick you want to
take a break have a cigarette do it you
get extra time thank you he's gonna
tickle you all right all right we're
gonna take a quick break Chris will make
his eighth pick his fourth pick but the
eighth and final pick and we'll
otherwise clean up shop and close up
shop and get the hell out of here PFT la
would be back
after this
we're redrafting to 2012 draft based on
the teens that have those picks I took
Russell Wilson number one to the cult's
Sims has Andrew Luck to Washington
number two I've got Kirk Cousins yes
Kirk Cousins hello Kara how are you baby
the Browns at number three Fletcher Cox
to the Vikings at four with Simms pick I
put Luke Kuechly in Jacksonville at five
Sims has Bobby Wagner in Dallas at six
I put Chandler Jones the pass rusher in
Tampa Bay at seven now the last pick
Chris you're on the clock
dolphins number eight what do they do
yeah I mean I could go I'm thinking like
T Y Hilton do I do Nick Foles okay I
mean Melvin Ingram I mean this is the
same draft they ended up dropping
olivier vernon to go across from Cameron
wake but I think of you know they go
Melvin Ingram they're gosh that's gonna
be I'm really stuck between whoa I want
to go Melvin Ingram or David DeCastro
those are the two guys I'm looking at I
think more than anything here to go okay
I think and okay I think I'm coming to
it I just want to take one more look
yeah I am going to go with Melvin the
Vikings are about to take your pick
going Melvin Ingram I'm gonna go with
Melvin Ingram at this time
yeah Melvin Ingram I mean he's been one
of the best edge defenders in football
coming off the edge he's great and stop
in the run of course he can you know
rush the passer and be really disruptive
that way but I look at that and go man
him and Cameron wake across from each
other that would be kind of a special a
special combination and maybe we're
talking about a whole different thing
down in Miami of those two were together
yeah I agree with you on Melvin Ingram I
mean but there are other hey quarterback
driven League that year they took Ryan
Tannehill would you take Ryan Tannehill
or Nick Foles if you had to choose only
between those two guys oh gosh that is a
really good question mm I'm gonna say
Nick Foles yes I'm gonna say I'm gonna
take Nick Foles they're over Ryan
Tannehill I like Ryan Tannehill more
than you know he gets credit for at
times you know you talked about it
earlier in the show just you know I
think when healthy if you go back and
look at you know the winds and the
numbers and and the things and the way
he's played it's it's a little better
than I ever gave him credit for
until I kind of went back and gave it a
deeper dive look so I like Ryan
Tannehill but Nick Foles you know the
clutch decision-making and you know me
Mike his ability to throw the football
with pressure around him I think is as
good as anybody in the NFL right now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports